ce second tour madame le pen et monsieur
macron
représentait à peine plus du tiers des
électeurs inscrits
les urnes ont tranché madame le pen est
battu
la france a refusé clairement des lui
confier son avenir et c'est une très
bonne nouvelle
pour l'unité de notre peuple
à présent monsieur macron est le plus
mal élu des présidents de la vème
république
sa monarchie présidentielle
survie par défaut est sous la contrainte
d'un choix biaisé
il surnage dans un océan d'abstention
de bulletins blancs et nuls
ma pensée se tourne
vers les futures victimes de cette
situation
les personnes qui vivent du rsa et
devront travailler gratuitement pendant
20 heures
les personnes usées qui partiront à la
retraite trois ans plus tard
les personnes prises à la gorge
financièrement et qui ne verront pas les
prix être bloqué
les personnes qui savent à quel point
l'inaction écologique de monsieur macron
est un crime
les personnes qui voient avec tristesse
l'état détruit et le pays vendu à la
découpe
à toutes et à tous je dis ne vous
résignez pas au contraire
entrer dans l'action
franchement massivement
la démocratie peut nous donner de
nouveau le moyen de changer de cap
le troisième tour comment ce soir
les 12 et 19 juin ont lieu les élections
législatives
vous pouvez battre monsieur macron et
choisir un autre chemin
le 12 et 19 juin un autre monde est
encore possible si vous élisez une
majorité je dis bien la majorité de
députés de la nouvelle union populaire
qui doit s'élargir
le bloc populaire qui s'est constituée
autour de ma candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
est dans ce pays dorénavant le terrain
et à qui peut tout changer s'il se
rassemble s il s'élargit
le 12 et 19 juin en vous appelant à mes
lire comme premier ministre je vous
appelle en vérité à faire vivre un
nouvel avenir en commun pour notre
peuple
courage action
détermination refus toujours de la
fatalité et de la résignation
vive la france vive la république
[Musique]